you're in the number one movie in the
country I am John wick chapter yeah now
very exciting we just I mean not for
nothing we just decimated the Avengers
this weekend yeah just crushed them yeah
take that Thor yeah no I love the
Avengers so are you excited about this
this part you know I love these movies I
don't know if you've seen these movies
yeah they're so fun and I was such a fan
and I'm gonna have a very small part my
I play a character called the tick-tock
man and very integral character JK it's
a very small role but we just got
greenlit for John wick for God yesterday
know which I'm very excited about and I
can on this program report an exclusive
which is the title of that movie again
my characters called the tick-tock man
and it is John wick chapter for wick in
the tick and it is just me Keanu Reeves
getting into Conan hyejung all right now
would you be surprised to be very
surprised go on a double date in the
movie that doesn't go well you know
because he's got his dog that's with him
all the time giving me an animal oh you
have an animal getting a parrot okay
pretty excited about it
I spoilers for John wick for I kill John
wick
and then the next movie is just tick
tock man chronicles tick tock man
Chronicles John wick 5 chapter chapter 5
tick tock man Chronicles okay yeah well
I'm glad you got all of this off your
chest
oh I wanted to I could talk about this
for the next hour I know you could did I
set up the clip enough I think you did
love to set up here of this is you your
tick tock man and you encountered John
wick and this is from chapter 3 para
bellum
[Music]
Hey look you you just as soon as I make
you better but I know better man I know
better I know it up
tick-tock mr. wick tick-tock
tick tock no time to dilly-dally mr.
wick John wick chapter 3 Powerball is in
theaters now I think they're all gonna
get Jason Mantzoukas